have you guys seen the um
sound of Freedom that movie no there's
some good movies lately I have to see
that one
I mean these but big names big
Blockbusters yeah there's some monologue
[__] that we got you know we pulled up
in our uh I saw that chat earlier in the
week we'll talk about Barbie Barbie's
obviously a stupid ass movie and you
know
people that think it's greater
not part of my tribe but um I would
definitely recommend going to see the
sound of Freedom over that if you had to
pick one it's um
especially if you got you know younger
kids within the right range it's
probably worthwhile showing them the
reality of the world out there and the
reality of how the world can actually be
versus how we're told it is
from that angle anyway
did you see it rick yeah it's good
it's good
um this weekend I've I've heard when you
ever whenever you hear people say things
about oh the US is a terrible place they
had slavery or what not I always try to
remind them that there's more slaves now
than there were any given time back in
that certain time range and in Period
and a lot of it is
people that are unfortunately child
trafficked or they call them here white
slavery so there's a big demand for
lighter skin people because they can put
them into s3x work and they they command
price that's actually a real thing it's
very common a lot of people are ignorant
to that fact yeah they make a big deal
of it um I guess publicly I saw a lot of
people trying to condemn like you know
Colombia as a result of that film and
it's like Yo dude
that's just one place that happens and
it's probably not even
responsible for the largest percentage
of uh child work in that area uh versus
other parts in the world very often is
it
well I mean like you've got these you've
got these asshats that that you know
they get off the hook all the time like
you know the guys that are friends of
the friends of the politicians that are
the criminals that make the real laws
like Sam Bank Freedom and all these guys
that got let off recently and you've got
Mr uh pedophile island with all these uh
presidents and uh billionaires that
visited yeah so this is just a small you
know part of the puzzle but it but it
does exist it's a reality if you have
small kids you should definitely make
them aware of uh
how the world actually works because
they get fed a lot of [__] that they
don't really uh understand so anyway
yeah what's the figure I just looked it
up uh there's an estimate of 90 112 five
or 112 500 prostituted children in the
U.S so that's disgusting yeah that's
quite a bit you know ideally it would be
zero but that's a lot
I mean they're in the us alone yeah and
they're and they're trying to normalize
this Behavior they're calling it uh
What's the phrase you know the woke
phrase they use for it like minor
attracted person or something like that
or some isn't that disgusting isn't it
you know like oh let's just you know
you know I hate how mainstream media and
how these how these you know the Optics
of these politics and these sound bites
that they use try it's like Kinder
friendlier diversions of something
that's [__] you know it's like if it
looks like [__] and it smells like [__]
can we just call it [__] you know can we
stop pretending that it's something that
it's not
like body positivity oh being a big fat
really that's what that is yeah did you
notice on the um on the ladies night
show that we did the other day
um when I asked the gals about lizzo I
said you know like what do you think of
lizzo and you know the body positivity
and say not a single one of them wanted
to have a single stance on it they
didn't want to have an opinion they'll
have opinions about what guys should be
doing but when it comes to
um you know publicly talking about
something that would
probably have diabetes bad you know like
inflammation in their body all that sort
of stuff it's like nope don't want to
have an opinion about that we'll be
neutral right
yeah guys if you're watching uh hot
chicks don't bang fat guys I'll throw it
out there for you no problem solved they
just have to say that publicly like uh
Paul Benjamin of Apex mindset says the
good chimp bad chimp type thing
yeah I mean like unless you're rich
obviously that's that's the only time
you'll get laid if you're a fat dude
um but there are no chubby chaser dating
sites for uh women chasing big big dudes
you know they still they still value the
conventionally strong masculine traits
that they find attractive
um
let me read this monologue here that we
found on the um Barbie movie
um
there's four slides here so just give me
a second it says it's literally
impossible to be a woman so this is
basically summing up what I guess uh
reporters and bloggers and you know
these
I guess movie response critics sort of
talk about with the movie
and I'm assuming this is more left
leading you know the way that it reads
but it goes it's literally impossible to
be a woman you are so beautiful you are
so smart and it kills me that you don't
think you're good enough like we always
have to be extraordinary but somehow
we're always doing it wrong
you could use that exact same sound bite
and substitute woman for man can't you
um you have to be thin but not too thin
you can never say you want to be thin
you have to say you want to be healthy
but also you have to be thin you have to
have money no you don't you just have to
be pretty agreeable and not a [__]
basically you have to have money uh and
you can't ask for money because that's
crass uh you have to be a boss no you
don't but you can't be mean
it goes on to say you have to lead but
you can't squash other people's ideas
you're supposed to love being a mother
but don't talk talk about your kids all
the damn time you have to be a career
woman no you don't but also always be
looking out for other people uh you have
to answer for men's bad behavior since
when uh I mean half the time it's made
up which is insane but if you point that
out you're accused of complaining
uh you're supposed to stay pretty for
men well yeah I mean it's like men are
expected to stay successful for women
right women are Beauty objects men are
success objects but not so pretty that
you tempt them too much or that you
threaten other women because you're
supposed to be part of The Sisterhood
but always stand out always be grateful
but never forget the system is rigged so
find I mean when complaining about a
rich person so so find a way to
acknowledge that but also always be
grateful yeah
uh you have to never get old I mean we
all age so I don't know what that's
about never be rude never show off never
be selfish never fall down never fail
never show Fear gee this sounds a lot
like encouraging men to chase Excellence
doesn't it doesn't sound like uh you
know the descriptive behaviors for a
feminine woman literally no one holds
them to those standards that's all made
up this is all made up in their you know
caffeinated brain right uh half of it's
just wishing Nuance didn't exist either
yeah well let me finish it because I
mean like you had a great a great chunk
of feedback to that uh never get out of
line it's never too hard it's too uh
contradictory and nobody gives you a
medal and says thank you and it turns
out in fact that not only are you doing
everything wrong but also everything is
your fault uh it's I'm just so tired of
watching myself in every single Other
Woman tie herself into knots so that
people will like us
and if all of that is also true for a
doll referencing the Barbie movie Just
representing a woman then I don't even
know
anyway get some good feedback on that do
you want me to read what you wrote or do
you want to read it out or you just want
to stay there yeah you go ahead and read
it if you like okay
give me a second I got this caffeine gum
on my mouth and it tastes like a [__]
answer
sorry not caffeine is nicotine um
so Jake said I say it all the time
women's worst opponents and judges in
Social regards and beauty standards as
other women
female media culture magazines blogs Etc
are the ones setting more convoluted
ridiculous standards preaching that it
is what men want women reading this
garbage blame men because they're told
that it's men that set those standards
when in reality it's female mainstream
media and the beauty industry that just
constantly looking for more red meat and
[__] to talk so they can't they
aren't cast into irrelevance they've
been tricked into Mass consumerism
tuition clothes makeup shoes Etc tapping
into their competition anxiety drive and
we've taken the blame for it most men
just want to check that's Pleasant and
behavior on the eyes and in bed and no
money telling women not to rock up
student debt sorry there's no money in
telling women not to rock a student debt
not to blow money on shitloads of makeup
and not to fill their faces with box
wine and food delivery
it's a little bit of uh reality it's a
cold hard uh truth I suppose
um
I don't know like like you know like
women complaining about a Barbie movie
which is clearly you know based in
[__] total fiction I mean just I
didn't watch it but I mean if you look
at the trailer it's clearly a fictional
standpoint on
love and relationships and reality but
you know it's like oh it's too hard it's
too contradictory and we have to do this
we have to do that and it's like
women just really have to do two things
just be nice and be and be pretty that's
it I mean it's not hard to get a
valuable guy if you're nice and pretty
and you know where to you know Place
yourself in the right room and not be a
hoe and you know do all the right things
it's it's not that difficult you don't
need to climb the corporate ladder you
don't need degrees you don't need a
you know 17 degrees frame to Mahogany
with little letters after your name just
be attractive that's it be attractive
and nice I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out